the jurogan experience hey i was
supposed to do this the other day but we
didn't the candles i had a party uh
party i had a podcast it was kind of a
party uh shane gillis mark norman
this morning at the gym careful once you
open that bag it's not gets gnarly
oh jesus yes smelling salts you're not
supposed to open your eyes and waft it
don't sniff it bro just the just that
that's why i've kept it i took it out of
my house and that's fully sealed yeah
just smelling salt can i try one well
you don't try one it's like
just open up the back this is the idea
okay uh there's a gentleman on the
podcast the other day is a power lifter
rob kearney and rob uh told us we were
talking about smelling sauce the gay
power lifter guy yeah his world's
strongest gay is his instagram
and he was telling us about
the got him
it's [ __ ] nasty um he was telling us
about smelly salts we're talking about
smelling salts and about like it's a big
deal he has actually a smelling salt
sponsor so jamie went out and got some
smelling salts all right and just open
that bag don't even
by the way the bottle is completely
sealed
okay but if you just open up the bag
you'll smell how [ __ ] ranked that
[ __ ] is it also has the emblem from the
saw movies on it which is way dicey get
a whiff
wow wow oh and that's a sealed bottle
we're live
it's fully plastic sealed
i feel like we should open it but if we
open it is it bad to open in this room
yeah but we can handle some the warning
says like don't don't smell it more than
a couple times a day so like look but
listen this smell like folks i just want
you to know we're freaking out about the
smell and the plastic is
you hear that that's theo taking the
plastic off the bottle so that [ __ ] was
sealed up oh my god i'll do a couple of
these [ __ ] on i've been through some
things okay get a whiff
bro it isn't rock spill it yeah you're
not you're supposed i think you're
supposed to leave it in there i don't
think you're supposed to take it okay
okay you have to shake it though i think
you just take a whiff
they do that right before they lift are
you okay
before they lift what bro before they
lift weights you're not supposed to
before they lift the [ __ ] universe
before they lift their future take a
gander on that with you something face
headed daddy take a gander on that with
that face hitter joe there's something
about just holding it up over here is
rough but there's something about this
stuff that like when you take a whiff of
it right before you lift it's supposed
to like
jolt your
your nervous system right is that the
idea i think so you forget about
everything else except for that i have
no take a ride on that hitter
boom
oh my god aloe vera goes down
holy [ __ ]
is that shocking oh my god
oh my god that's stunning i would have
never imagined
take that to the fights this week that's
something you buy at a nelly club
oh jesus give me that plastic bag dude
oh that's so unnecessary you want to try
it i'm great oh you should take a hit i
believe you no it's not that bad well
it's not it's not painful is it worse
than that rice that drink
yeah no get a hit jamie you're gonna be
fine you're an adult my friend megan
gave me this drink from mexico it's like
turpentine yeah hey lights on fire
whoa right
like whoa nelly
i'm tearing up i got one of my eyes
tiered what is that is that's ammonia
right i don't know what the [ __ ] it is
and it's a
rob takes a sniff of that [ __ ] for a
powerless i feel like i've smelled that
when the kid pukes in elementary school
that's what they used to like
clean it up or spray well i think that's
different that's in rock form i think
that's much more potent you okay yeah
i'm good just one point
oh yeah that's attack huh oh boy and i
can't handle that smoke baby so rob like
will take a sniff of those before he
like lifts a 450 pound log over his head
i could see that i definitely feel more
clear i feel like it's a whole bag of
native american right there baby
do you think you should take a sniff in
that before you go on stage maybe
oh
i don't know he almost gets you two
separate from your thoughts right it's
so wild
yeah
it's so jolting
it's good man thank you for that i think
all those power lifters use it though
don't i think all of them do right most
mostly it's a big deal i've seen those
guys they do and sometimes they get
smacked in the face like their their
girlfriend will smack them they've
there's a bunch of these videos oh
there's one dude they're tough in their
cheeks
from being knocked out right so that's
the same like when they break the little
thing and they yeah i think that's
exactly the same thing yes yeah oh that
would wake me up i'd be dead i'd bring
me back at least for a few minutes
wow
jesus christ and we are back man we're
back whoa my nose is still infected with
it like when i take a deep breath i
still smell it
imagine how small those particles are
and they're just inside your nose
well also we didn't even get any of the
dust out like that's in a rock people
don't understand i think also do you see
it in a it's in a yeah i didn't even
look in like a crystal or i just trust
you
i didn't look in there
but i just went like that i just i
didn't even i didn't have it more than
like five inches from my nose like it's
still in yeah wide open in the room
exactly i like it it's in your nose
yeah
oh god i'm ready i'm here i i i like
that a little i'll hit a marker sometime
i'll hit a uh markers
i'll go three hits on duster dude not
enough to [ __ ] damage myself but i
will take a risk with it you know
there's something about magic markers
delicious
oh this yeah i think even those hops
that's a nice smell and then smile at
somebody after that was my favorite
thing to do
do you like gasoline when you pump your
gas
dude we had a guy drink gasoline on
halloween one time this kid todd got had
to get his stomach
why did he do that i don't know
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify